E
AXXERS ARE
USING THE SA TCS AS CUS
RECRUITED BY A
CUK ANE THE FEAR  ME  THEE TOTTS
AND OTHEUSAN EXPERS.ARE WI US.C
>>E ARE SEVERA OTR
MOVEMENT O. TWO P
WHING.
VITAFORMATG
NDTHTE
E DELIBERATE
OR
OP'SG D ANALYTIC MO  JUDGING.
I WANT TO TEC THAT
IGOF THERE IS REAWEE ABLE TO R
GET AWNGT AL, TRDAVI19 IS E YOU
ME DANGE BUT THERE
VER ER.K ATACTSNDE THDAO , I' H
ATTAINTTING US I  ROOWATCHING MN
UNDERSTAND L OF THEIR MINDSILRO
THEM.
OPE E WORLD WHERE YOU HAVE
INFORMATION YOD
S  DOWN THATRABBITOLPECIAL OOLOD
ONLIEVED WAS
COED BY SATAN.I WAS TOUT TO DO
I WAS DEBE TE CISTOV ALONGIT
AND THEN THED TOTHE MESSIAH ANDR
AID MAMOVIE TO WOULDIF. CULT, I
S AN
OOTHE CTOR THAO  YOU ABOTH
I WANTE MORE
PEN TEY WHER ARE
IF YOU HAVE ANVAPHOBIAYOU CAN'EU
MODER
ELEVATOR EMERGENCY BRAKEE WORST
U'LL    EE ON YOURSELFE WAYS TT
OVER THE FEAR.OP TALTO THEIREDOD
THE .HEINATE THEIRES BUT AINEI
TOR OR HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL?
Y IS  NEEDS TO BLEITH  QUESTIO
T THING THAT
I'LL FEEBAFOA DAY ORD
THESINFECT
ARE
CO